my name is Jacob ward I wear two hats I
am both a PhD student here at Carnegie
Mellon University I'm also the program
manager for analysis at the US
Department of Energy
so especially excited to be able to wear
both hats at this event today our next
panel is smart cities transportation
infrastructure electrification and the
autonomous sharing economy I'm happy to
announce an exceptional set of panelists
including Kosta Samaras who is not only
the moderator but also my PhD advisor an
assistant professor of civil and
environmental engineering here at
Carnegie Mellon University his research
spans energy climate change vehicle
automation and Defense analysis and he
directs the Center for engineering and
resilience for climate adaptation he is
an affiliated faculty member in Carnegie
Mellon's Scott Institute for energy
innovation the College of Engineering
energy science technology and policy
program and by courtesy a faculty member
in the H John Heinz the third College
Kosta is also an adjunct senior
researcher at the RAND Corporation not
next to Kosta
but framing Kosta will do sandwich
introductions we have joe dimaggio
director of business development for
Duquesne Light Company Joe is the
director of business development there
he is responsible for identifying and
executing on new investment
opportunities and developing the
company's long term business strategy
including its role in advancing
transportation electrification jumping
across the stage a little bit there we
have Darren Epps who's a product
development specialists who helps lead
electric transportation efforts at
atlanta-based Southern companies energy
and from an innovation center mr. Epps
is currently focused on developing a
next-generation electric vehicle charger
second use electric vehicle programs and
innovative turnkey charging bundles for
municipalities and fleets we also have
another colleague of mine Sarah Alexa
back here on your left-hand side of the
stage
she is the energy efficient Mobility
Systems Manager at the US Department of
Energy where she manages transportation
projects that help smart cities increase
energy efficiency and reduce emissions
through the convergence of connectivity
automation shared mobility multimodal
urban transport and Evi charging
infrastructure she also wears lots of
hats
back on the other side of the stage we
have Karina Rick's the director of the
city of Pittsburgh department of
mobility and infrastructure the
department is responsible for the
transportation of people and goods
throughout the city of Pittsburgh and
for managing the operation of and access
to the public right-of-way and finally
in the center we have sherry Shapiro who
is the senior manager of public affairs
for Pennsylvania and Delaware for uber
sherry leads ubers public and government
affairs efforts in Pennsylvania and
Delaware she spearheaded Ebert's
successful campaign in 2016 to legalize
ride-sharing across Pennsylvania please
look on our panel and cost it with that
I give it to you all for being here and
it's an honor to be introduced by one of
our great graduate students co-advised
with some of my colleagues here in the
Scott Institute for energy innovation
and to be joined by such an illustrious
panel of transportation leaders our
panel today is about the future and
about the future of smart cities future
transportation the integration with the
sharing economy the integration with the
electricity sector and I wanted to
mention that today the Scott Institute
for energy innovation kicked off our our
latest update for our emissions index
that you can find out emissions index
org and that helps us understand the
impacts of maybe charging electric
vehicles or using electricity across the
country so I invite all of you all to
visit that website before we get too
deep into that I wanted to start here by
understanding the future of a place like
Pittsburgh and we can I'm gonna ask the
panel and we'll start with Karina you
know help us imagine what a smart city
means to everyday folks and what the
future of a place like Pittsburgh means
to everyday people and maybe you can
help us understand what will a place
like Pittsburgh look like in 25 years
from a transportation or energy
perspective 25 years it's really helpful
to look backwards to see where we've
been maybe not 25 years but but maybe
looking back 40 years when Pittsburgh
was a city twice its size
we were 600,000 plus people in this city
we had a robust economy many many people
the primary commuting modes at that time
were we're walking using one of our 770
sets of stairs to get to and from the
mills we had a expansive transit system
we're continuously digging up rails that
I didn't even know existed underneath
our streets of the vast streetcar system
that once plied the city but we also had
a lot of challenges we had horrific air
quality we had very compromised rivers
we paid a price for that economic
robustness that we had in the city so I
think looking forward when we look
forward 25 years I think we take the
best of the past but we also learned
from it make a smart city when we talk
about energy when we talk about and at
CMU inevitably autonomy that we also
need to think about those lesser
celebrated modes of walking and
bicycling and transit use the city of
the future that I see is one where we
again see walking and bicycling as being
some of the primary means of getting
around the city especially for those
very short trips that make up more than
60% of the trips that we make in our
daily lives when I think about autonomy
and electrification I really want to see
that pushed into the transit sector not
necessarily the low capacity autonomous
vehicles but higher capacity buses
trains and others that fly our city so
that we can really dramatically reduce
the operational costs of that mode and
have a level of service that is as as
great as we enjoy doing peak hour with
very marginal costs additional to that
system and so we're single occupant or
low occupancy electric all-electric
autonomous mobility really is an
ancillary supplement to that backbone
system where the majority of our travel
is taken by bicycling and walking and
transit right so sherry what does it
look like for uber in what's Ebers
vision of a future city 25
so first I want to say that it looks a
lot like what Karina just articulated
the idea for uber is to have a very
multimodal means of transportation
public transit will always be the most
efficient and the most environmentally
beneficial way for people to get from
place to place bicycles and walking but
so it will be a very multimodal universe
powered by electricity or something
better if we can get there and most
importantly for us both electric and
shared shared is really a piece of this
that we need to bring in beyond just
public transit but shared rides in
individual cars as well something along
the lines of 70% of trips now are taken
in cars with one person in them if we
don't start shifting that mindset as
well as adding the electric and
autonomous pieces to it we'll be missing
out on a great opportunity to benefit
cities so you mentioned the electric
part and maybe we can go over to Joe and
help us understand how an electric
utility especially a local distribution
company views what a smart city looks
like 25 years from now sure thanks yeah
to build off both the Korean and
Cherry's comments I think we recognized
that the city 25 years from now in that
in the transportation sector electricity
is going to be potentially the primary
fuel source at least a much more
substantial fuel source so I was
actually looking at some projections
preparing for our talk today and some
industry outlooks are actually
forecasting that over 50% of light-duty
passenger cars by 2040 will be evie so
that's that's a massive shift from boy
from where we're at today so as the
utility in the provider of that fuels
we're taking steps now to prepare
ourselves for that future so - excuse me
the spring of last year we made an
announcement a strategic announcement
that that we were going to be advancing
and playing a strategic role advance in
transportation electrification in the
region
we started by electrifying our own fleet
so to really learn the benefits of and
the operations of electric vehicles we
actually now we have 18 vehicles that
have been electrified in our own fleet
and then over the next several years
really for the foreseeable future we're
projecting to invest nearly 20 percent
of our annual fleet budget in electric
vehicles so so some significant
investment on that front and then really
taking the next step
looking at deploying charging
infrastructure to understand how how
charging a vehicles impacts our
distribution system that's another
massive step that we're taking and
really illustrated by the partnership
that we announced earlier this year with
uber so as we're trying to increase the
number of uber
evie drivers dukey and lights really
going to play the role in to helping
deploy that the fast charging
infrastructure that's needed for those
uber evie drivers so so those are some
of the steps that that we're taking to
prepare ourselves for for that for that
shift and the transportation sector in
the future there maybe you can build on
that coming from a different type of
utility our our utilities ready for this
type of environment what can they do I
think we're getting ready now I think
we're getting ready now there we go I
think we see the future of
transportation as connected autonomous
shared and electric the question we're
working to solve is how would you
support the infrastructure to
autonomously and we talked about that
backstage I'm sorry to report we did not
come up with any solutions but we you
know right now cars are parked 96% of
the time that is a market that's asking
to be disruptive disrupted right now my
car's been at the Atlanta Airport since
yesterday we'll be there
today tomorrow no just sitting there
doing nothing could it be putting power
back on the grid I Drive a Nissan Leaf
in the future state yes could it be
working for me right now and delivering
goods in the future state I think I
think it will we talk all the time to
builders in Atlanta who are putting up
parking structures and they are trying
to think about how to build a parking
structure for the next 50 years and do
the bill at the parking deck so it can
be easily converted in to say more
condos because I think everyone sees
this happening it's happening right now
bringing up the Atlanta Airport again
they had plans to add a lot more parking
and they tore them up because you know
it's it's cheaper if you're gonna be at
the airport for two or three or four
more days to just take an uber to the
airport instead of parking and paying 16
a day so in that in that same vein we
think the cars will be electric because
the cost per mile is so much lower when
you drive an electric versus gas so that
that's sort of how just building on
everyone else this point how we see the
future of mobility in Atlanta and Beyond
great so the Sarah works at the
Department Energy which is a
multi-headed organization as many of you
know mostly responsible for the design
and safeguarding our nuclear weapon
system as well as the advancement of you
know high energy physics and science a
small part of that which we think is a
very important part is kind of
developing the next generation of our
energy technology and maybe Sarah you
can give us an understanding of how is
the department energy preparing for this
world of shared automated electric
transportation and what are the things
on the horizon that we might be able to
expect so at the Department of Energy
soon our biggest goals to to help cities
move forward in the next 25 years we're
working alongside the Department of
Transportation to make mobility more
equitable make it more accessible and
make it more affordable to everyday
American consumers drivers of vehicles
so what we're working on always is
for example with electric vehicles is
going to be investments in research and
development to bring down the costs of
the vehicles so we do that primarily or
the largest portion of our budget goes
toward improving battery capacity and
battery resilience through since 2008
we've brought down battery costs by
eighty percent that's significant and we
still have so much room to go further on
the other side of the coin we're working
to increase the battery capacity so
every year automakers that we're working
with in partnership are putting out
vehicles that have higher and higher
longer and longer vehicle ranges so
again this goes back to making these
vehicles more affordable and more
convenient for drivers and it's not just
about making mobility more convenient
with electric vehicles but we still have
to think about all those traditional
internal combustion engine vehicles on
the road as well so how are we making
those vehicles more fuel efficient as
well and we're making big gains there
through the advancements in
high-strength steel light weighting
reducing rolling resistance and tires so
there's just a lot of gains that can be
made with increasing vehicle efficiency
and I'll talk a little bit more later
probably about some of the systems level
work that we're doing well sure you
mentioned the importance of sharing and
how do we get to sharing we know that
sharing is helpful for the environmental
impacts of automation and and for
transportation but do we think sharing
is likely and what are the some of the
barriers to sharing and I get asked a
lot will autonomous vehicle to be shared
or where they be privately owned or will
it be a combination of both what are
your thoughts on that so let's go to the
experience that we've had
uber has a product in many cities called
uber pool
and uberpool is exactly what it sounds
like a pickup one passenger and then you
pick up another passenger who's going in
the same route and direction and then
you drop them off the two barriers to
carpooling have historically been
inconvenience you go with Larry and
morning Larry has to stay late for a
meeting and you've lost your ride home
and cost right it's easier and less
expensive to simply drive your own car
no aggravation what we found is that
through technology this is really broken
through on the first primary barrier by
pooling people by trip as opposed to by
individual person you get rid of that
inconvenience and uncertainty factor
that's really been a huge change also
people will carpool if the cost is low
enough so by having pooled rides lowers
the cost and therefore people are more
likely to take them what we've found is
in pool cities about 20% of our rights
our pool rights and that is growing and
we're doing continual improvement to the
pool product excellent well I mean the
the comments that that Carina made in
the beginning which is about looking
backward and thinking about her past got
me thinking about our previous
transportation revolutions and how they
really opened up a lot of new access and
mobility for whole bunch of different
populations another thing that they also
did was sometimes bisect neighborhoods
wall off neighborhoods destroy
neighborhoods and I wonder how we can
make choices at the beginning of this
transportation revolution with the
hindsight of the things that we've done
wrong in the past so that we don't
repeat some of those mistakes and how
could a smart city also improve equity
environmental justice and access it's a
big question and it's something that we
really need to wrestle with again back
in the city of the past when walking and
bicycling and
transit were the dominant modes of
travel we did have less transportation
and equity these are very democratic
forms of mobility the the costs are very
flat across the board today the cost of
owning and operating a private
automobile is about $10,000 a year 920
I'm sorry ninety nine thousand two
hundred dollars per year according to
triple-a for every year that you own and
operate a vehicle and that's before you
pay for parking so that cost can go
significantly up that's per car per year
so for households that are earning below
the the median income that is a
substantial cost in the Pennsylvania
western Pennsylvania region our
households that are in the lower fifth
quintile of income their household
transportation costs are nearly double
what their household housing costs are
so transportation costs are about double
what housing costs are for the lowest
quintile income earners in the region so
it's very important that in part is
because we've built a society now in
this age that does require the owning
and operation and maintenance of a
private automobile if you are to get to
a number of the job centers that some of
the lowest income earners are most apt
to be matched with these job centers are
out in the suburban districts these job
centers are job reporting times are in
non peak times there in that off-peak
periods and very difficult to get to we
no longer really have that walk centric
urban form we no longer really have the
kind of ubiquitous transit service that
we had so I think again I'll keep
hitting this drum of autonomous electric
shared mobility means mass transit to
the extent that it can for cities that's
the best way that we can do it we have
3,000 mass transit vehicles in Allegheny
County we have hundreds of thousands of
privately owned vehicles so we really
the way to the future is to
expand that transit fleet increased mass
transit usage increase the efficiency
convenience and attractiveness of that
mode that can decrease the environmental
consequences which again
disproportionately affect to lower
income populations more isolated
populations it can increase their access
to jobs and employment and can help them
raise their standard of living my
department is a new department and I
like to sort of repeat the mission that
we've adopted which is which is drawn
from research done in Harvard University
that says that commuting is the single
largest factor that influences a
households ability to escape poverty
their access to transportation is more
important on the quality of the schools
or the quality of the housing in these
areas and so the mission of my
department is to provide the physical
mobility that's necessary for the
economic mobility that people seek and
and we do this through the promotion of
shared electric autonomy shared electric
mobility that does really again
democratize access to Economic
Opportunity
excellent well we the theme that we keep
hearing is shared electric mobility Joe
and Darren mentioned some of the things
that the utilities are doing to prepare
the grid for potential charging but
maybe you can give us a sense about some
of the barriers to electric vehicle mass
adoption and and when we might see a
whole bunch of these vehicles on the
road maybe we start with dinner so I
think one of the barriers right now and
Ann mentioned this earlier is going to
be the infrastructure if you look at the
electric vehicle market right now
they're the models are getting more
sophisticated the battery batteries are
getting bigger the ranges are getting
longer the technology is getting better
for charging what's not kept up as much
as the infrastructure in that and that's
because there's a tough ROI on on
infrastructure you know a fast charger
is about $30,000 could be 20 to 40 and
installation and you're charging $2 you
know an hour that's that's a long time
to get your money back so like Ann said
earlier right
Latorre process that helps the utility
consider charging infrastructure as an
extension of the grid I think would be a
lot better you know we were looking at
350 kilowatt hour charging right now
hi-hi-hi power charging I think this
changes and probably around 2025 so when
you look at the the what it costs to
drive a gas vehicle what you just
mentioned that has continued to go up as
regulations get gets stronger the cost
to buy an electric vehicle continues to
go down and I think around 2025 those
lines meet and at that point it's just
cheaper to buy an electric vehicle than
a gas vehicle even without considering
the savings in fuel costs the savings
and maintenance so I think 2025 is kind
of the date we have we have pegged I
think it's um what was some of the
automakers have pegged as when the
parity cost parity is reached with gas
and electric vehicles Joey you have any
ad on that front yeah I mean just agree
with a lot of the things that Darren
said and if you look at as far as the
2025 date I think that coincides with
many of the major automakers have
announced over the past several months
billions and billions and billions of
dollars that they're investing in
vehicle electrification Ford announced
that they're going to be investing I
think 11 billion dollars by 2022 GM's
gonna have 20 additional Eevee models
they kind of you run through the list of
all the major auto manufacturers and and
these companies are focusing significant
dollars in this space and I think you
know I've always kind of went by the old
adage of you follow the money and
they're investing the money in this
space and I think with that with the
decrease in battery cost that was
mentioned by Sarah earlier you're gonna
hit a point where it just makes more
sense the performance of the electric
vehicle is better you don't have to take
it into the shop to get the oil change
so there's just a lot of benefits to
driving electric and there's just a
couple other points you know locally I
think that we're not as mature in
western Pennsylvania some other evie
markets you know there's roughly 1500
vehicles within our Duquesne Light
service territory Eevee's the
registered as at the end of the year so
we we still have some barriers to cross
as far as education goes so that's that
that's something that we're trying to do
is the utility we're trying to educate
our customers where we've been the title
sponsor at the Pittsburgh Home and
Garden Show for 20-plus years I think
now so the past couple of years we've
put together a significant piece of our
exhibit has been dedicated purely to to
electric vehicle education it's part of
the partnership with uber a big
component of that will be partnering
with the local nonprofit to be
determined to help educate over drivers
that will in turn help educate over
riders so we think that that crossing
that education barrier is another
significant piece for a market that's
still kind of at the early stages that
we are at here in Western PA great well
so one of the things that we've done a
Carnegie Mellon for a long time through
my colleagues at the vehicle
electrification group is understanding
the environmental impacts of so maybe
Sarah you can help us understand will
shared automated electric vehicles be
any better for the environment what if I
were to live you know two hours away and
and and for driving a lot more what is
the grid gonna look like how do we
assess if these are gonna be good or not
it's a great question and conveniently
the Department of Energy has a brand new
program that we've just stood up to
answer these questions it's called the
energy efficient mobility systems
program and if there's any for all the
students that are in the room if you
want an exciting hot area to do research
in and hint-hint there may be money here
in the near near future there already is
but there will be more check out Google
do e energy efficient mobility systems
and so what this program is doing is its
looking to understand how we increase
this is a new metric mobility energy
productivity so how do we increase the
the bang for the buck that we get on
every unit of goods or people moved we
know that with the advent of autonomous
vehicles and increase in share
mobility the VMT is likely going to rise
we think that there's going to be an
increased accessibility for more people
to move more and the administration is
very supportive of that we should not be
hindering people's accessibility and
ability to move but how do we do it in
the most energy-efficient way
so of course this is looking at
increased use of mass transit increased
use of shared mobility limiting empty
miles driven and doing all of this in
the most energy-efficient way possible
and we're not just talking about them
when we think about smart cities and
energy and mobility a lot of people
think strictly of electric vehicles and
I just want people to be thinking about
how much bigger it is than that it's not
just EVs it's about doing all of our
mobility in the most efficient way
possible and so what the energy
efficient mobility assistance program is
doing is we're starting to think with
cities how do we harness the power of
data the massive amounts of data that we
have access to in our mobility systems
and use that to increase the efficiency
of those systems and so working with
partners like uber for example actually
in one of our living labs projects we're
looking at how we can do just that
so we're doing a work in five activity
areas but too that all highlight is the
smart mobility Laboratory consortium
which five national labs NREL Idaho
National Lab Oak Ridge National Lab
Argonne National Lab and Lawrence
Berkeley National Lab are all part of
what we're doing research on advanced
fueling infrastructure needs connected
and automated vehicles urban science in
a couple other new discipline areas
where we're standing up just new
fundamental basic research endeavors in
this space to understand the energy
impacts with these technologies and then
our living labs projects are kind of the
the real world
technology integration or deployment of
these technologies and we're recording
data and we're getting working with
cities and the private sector to look at
this data and understand how we can make
more increase our mobility energy
productivity so definitely check out
those programs and an early finding when
we stood the program up we did a very
high-level bounding study just don't
connect connected and automated vehicles
and we found that there is the potential
to increase energy consumption by 200
percent or decrease energy consumption
by just making sure I have it right 60
percent so that is a huge range and it
just shows how much more work is needed
in this space hence the dollars going
into investments in research to
understand this better and help cities
make choices that are going to steer
them in the more energy-efficient
direction so you mentioned choices sure
you want to add to that I wasn't asking
what the policy landscape what are the
choice what are those choices right so
right so it's it's interesting you
should say that one of the areas that we
are particularly supportive of at uber
is congestion pricing are people making
the right decisions about what mode of
transportation to make at the right
times so you're really maximizing the
efficiency and the use of the most
efficient mode for the time of day or
activity and that is a really strong
lever that has been shown to work in the
different places that it's been in in
place like London and to use that lever
to achieve the goals that Sarah was
articulating Carina what do you think
about the policy landscape to encourage
some of the better outcomes in this
smarter City environment what are some
of the bigger choices that we might be
needing to consider over the next 10 to
15 years well I would concur with sherry
that we do need to understand sort of
what the monetization of
that's the wrong phrase I guess but that
there is a cost book of actual cost as
well as a social cost associated with
our mobility choices coming from the
city it also means that our revenues
will actually change we do get a
significant amount of revenue from from
parking for example in a shared an
autonomous mobility future it does mean
that we need to think about that
differently the significant costs the
significant revenue that funds the
investment and infrastructure and the
maintenance of our transportation
facilities is from liquid fuels tax
which we're all delighted to see go away
but we do need to then replace those
revenue sources with something else
because we're still going to need with
streets and bridges and sidewalks and
lights that we use there and so really
that's some of the critical questions
that are in front of cities right now
and States as well it's to understand
how do we promote this great green
transformation to more sustainable modes
of mobility which we very very much want
to see thrive and be adopted but at the
same time we need to backfill that so
that we can continue to fund the
maintenance and operations of our
transportation systems given that the
that the federal gas tax has not been
raised or indexed for inflation since
what's the appetite for of vehicle miles
traveled feet so vehicle miles traveled
there's I think that there's great
appetite for it and conceptually it
seems like a very good idea there's a
lot of issues associated with that and
various tests have been done to evaluate
that one of the issues is that right now
the the liquid fuels tax is gathered at
point-of-sale so if you're driving on
the Turnpike between Ohio and
Pennsylvania if you fuel up at a
Pennsylvania rest stop Pennsylvania gets
your money if you fuel up in Ohio rest
up Ohio gets your money if it's vehicle
miles try
we now have privacy concerns as to
understand where you're traveling when
and how far and at what times and that's
Cherie mentioned that's one of the
challenges with congestion pricing as
well as that it does sort of indicate a
need for tracking you in a way so
there's still some bugs to be worked out
on the vehicle miles traveled we've also
talked Robin Chase who's been a real
leader in this space around shared an
autonomous mobility has talked a lot
about having sort of a a volume tax for
lack of a better term which is
understanding if a human being generally
can travel taking up the space of about
you know three cubic feet in surface
area if you start to use modes like
private vehicle travel which actually
consume about a thousand square feet if
you're the only one in that vehicle
versus a higher occupancy mode that you
would you would then be charged for that
usage utilization of the right-of-way
and calculating it in various ways like
that yeah it's so interesting so a space
based tax rather than a weight or
efficiency tax yes there and that that's
important to figure out a new model
because in Georgia anyone who drives an
electric vehicle to make up with a gas
tax
they charge you every everyday on my
birthday I get two hundred dollar
registration fee to make this order make
up for the lack of fuel I'm using
meanwhile the average SUV driver pays
about 130 in gas tax a year so I'm
paying more than anybody in the state in
gas tax so there are nuts need to be a
discussion about a different model to
assess those speeds because I as a needy
driver I want the roads to be great I
want to pay my share but it's it's it's
not fair the way currently set up and
then other states are certain to follow
suit well as a recovering transportation
engineer I'm going to disappoint you and
say that neither you nor the SUV is
causing much road damage it's it's
nearly all heavy trucks that are that
are damaging the road on on a day-to-day
basis and there is a cross subsidy
between cars bikes SUVs towards towards
trucks owner on our roadways but and I'm
obligated to say snow snow winter yes
snow in our in our salting of the roads
a lot of this has been talked about with
the electrification of the
transportation sector as pretty key
towards this smart city and an advanced
mobility concept Joe and Darrin have
talked about the ability of the
infrastructure what about the generation
assets and and how we might continue to
see generation assets play into this
into this space will there be a lot of
distributed generation in cities 15
years from now or is it gonna be a more
still kind of centralized grid operation
you start would you start with Joe or
you want to start with there yeah I
could I could I can kick that one off oh
no I think where we're seeing more and
more interest in from a customer
perspective and with costs coming down
on distributed generation I do think
that you're going to see an uptick or
you know a greater prevalence of
distributed generation you know the
recent first energy solutions bankruptcy
filing the statements that they've made
regarding closing some of their biggest
Central Station facilities I think that
those are indicative of the time that
we're in so with that you know it's it's
imperative that we that we invest in our
distribution grid our distribution and
transmission grid assets to make sure
that we have the capacity they have the
the ability to take and to take into
account this pearl proliferation of
distributed and energy resources and I
think it was mentioned earlier as well
vehicles could could be a distributive
energy resource in the future and I
think that as we see increased adoption
of electric vehicles that that's just
another asset that we're going to have
to manage and then we're gonna have to
create a grid that is a platform to
manage all of these distributed energy
resources so we're investing those
dollars today with an eye towards the
future that it will be an environment
with with greater distributed generation
so we're testing that right now we have
two smart neighborhoods one in Georgia
and one in Alabama that are the one in
Georgia we have rooftop solar all the
appliances in the house will be
connected and smart and we want to test
how people interact with a smart home
and study how generation works off the
rooftop solar and that will also inform
our R&D also unfortunately the future of
home building so we want to learn that
the one in Alabama is a little bit
different it has all the the whiz-bang
devices in the house but the
neighborhood it's going to be powered by
a micro grid so a different technology
and again we want to study that it does
that make sense for future home building
so in both cases we partnered with the
home builder and we're all learning a
lot about the future of homes and it's
distributed generation the answer we're
also doing a pilot in Atlanta smart
cities pilot so we own a lot of light
poles in the in the southeast and we put
200 notes on light poles in Atlanta and
this will help us measure it has video
capabilities but help measure help the
city measure a traffic flow help people
with parking does gunshot detection that
immediately notifies the police when
their sound is made so we're learning
about all this now we have a little bit
more time in the southeast our rates are
among the lowest in the country under
our current models so but we want to
learn and we want to know what the
future looks like and that's what we're
working on
great well I want to shift gears though
because I got a question starting
getting questions from the audience and
one of them is for sherry and you know I
hesitate to ask this because it's about
a flying car and so the question is what
role do you see uber elevate to play in
in the future in the smart suit so is
this for real though I mean you're gonna
tell us we're just between us is it is
it really happening though I will tell
you so what what elevate is is a
commercialization of virtual takeoff a
vertical takeoff and landing
aircraft more easily understood as
drones for human transportation and the
answer is yes they are coming they're
coming sooner than you think we have a
group in Dallas and a partnership with
Bell Helicopter and a number of the
other aviation companies to see how that
can be part of the multimodal fleet do
you think it's gonna be
intercity or intra-city how are these
gonna work to be honest with you I don't
know down to that level of detail but
here's what I do think I think that when
you start to talk about automated
transportation we need to think beyond
what the near future the autonomous
vehicles the electric vehicles and into
what the far future might be and what I
love about coming here to Carnegie
Mellon is that so many of the people
here are taking a look and researching
and thinking about what that far future
is well one of the things we have to
worry about in the far future inside of
a smart city is new new threats and new
extreme events and maybe I want to tie
in resilience to this conversation a
little bit and how does like maybe we
start with Carina like what why does the
city even need to be resilient and how
can some of this technology enhance the
ability to cope with extreme events in
in a city so resilience means a lot of
different things and I think that that
is one of the things we maybe need to
talk about first it's not just about you
know that we can withstand
record-setting rains as we recently or
extreme temperatures or other kinds of
natural events like that there's also
social resiliency that's necessary and I
think that it's something that really we
do have to think about in the era of
autonomous mobility increased
privatization of mobility what happens
to our social cohesion to those those
those ties that bind us
to one another and build that sort of
social relationship that keeps us as a
strong community this is something that
we talk a lot about the the pressures
and stressors that lie on a city not
just from the environment but also from
the social aspects of the city and so we
do think about that and I already lost
the Train of no that's exactly where
trying to understand how some of these
technologies help us improve resilience
in in in a future city and maybe we
would ask Joe as a electricity provider
will the lights stay on more our lights
are pretty reliable in Pittsburgh right
now think they are I appreciate that but
it you know as we connect more things to
the Internet do you think that that will
still be the case and then how do we
make sure ensure we protect that yeah
you know I guess we're taking measures
every day to make sure that we have a
reliable resilient grid as you said we
do currently have one but it's always
keeping I am keeping an eye on the
future right so we're investing hundreds
of millions of dollars in a long-term
infrastructure improvement plan to to
better that and then also kind of along
the lines of the theme of distributed
generation we're going to be piloting a
micro grid at our Operations Center
campus on the north side of the city
where our our primary Operations Center
is so whenever there is extreme weather
events we're going to essentially hard
in the electrical infrastructure there
we're going to potentially pilot some
generation technologies there as well
but basically hardening and improving
the resiliency and the reliability of
that campus which is critical to making
sure the lights stay on for all of our
customers so I'd say that you know who
knows what the future holds but we are
at this point you know we're investing
significant dollars into preparing
ourselves for for that future there's a
lot of questions about the connection
between distributed generation and Evi
charging and so do you think that new
distributed generation assets would be
coupled with EB charging have you seen
examples where that work
and will it happen here in Pittsburgh or
in southern territories yeah I think
it's a conversation have so like I said
the future Vivi charging if you're gonna
try to simulate the gas station
experience and be done in five minutes
is what I mentioned earlier the 350
kilowatt hour charging that is a lot of
power that is when you look from a load
shape if you're thinking of us you know
in the rural setting on a corridor off
the side of an interstate one of those
chargers I mean the spikes would be
unbelievable
so I think you have to think about
pairing with battery storage or micro
grid fuel cell I think you have to have
those conversations because that that is
what's going to move the electric
transportation market I think that right
now fast charging 50 kilowatt hour
charging it takes about 30 minutes if
someone's in front of you you could be
there for an hour we've read about
fights at charging stations because
people are getting impatient please
don't fight people at charging stations
by the way but 350 kilowatt hour
charging sort of solves that and you
would need banks of those chargers so I
think that is while it's not something
we've seen yet I think that is that is
the future is pairing that with
distributed energy let me just chime in
there first thing in cost I think this
is an important point is that we don't
know what this future looks like all
that we know is that there's going to be
an increased penetration in EVs and
there's going to be in here at least I
believe there's going to be an increased
penetration of distributed generation so
this is a critical time for us to be
piloting things like southern like
Darren and southern are doing that
Duquesne Light is you know is just
really getting off the ground as I said
because we're at a relatively early
stage in terms of market maturity here
but it's critical for the utility I
think to be piloting technologies now to
understand how this is going to impact
our system to impact the community that
we serve so just a you know plug there
that we we need to be piloting
technologies now to better inform us for
the future I think we might have time
for one more question is that is that
okay okay so we're in the midst of a
technological revolution
in the transportation sector but the
transportation sector is now the largest
emitter of greenhouse gas emissions and
so Sarah we can start with you and
anybody can chime in what's it going to
take to deeply decarbonize the
transportation sector and when what are
the what a time lines look like what are
the levers that need to be pulled I
think that deep decarbonisation you know
it it really comes with diversifying
from petroleum to begin with and and
that is we still have a long road to go
from there and and we're also very
supportive of shifting to CNG use
especially in medium and heavy-duty
vehicles for the emission reduction
benefits they are are available there
for those types of vehicles at the
Department of Energy we find a lot of
research and development in solar wind
geothermal to to work towards bringing
down the cost of those technologies to
to to get more renewables on the grid so
I'll just leave it at either the future
of a deeply decarbonized transportation
sector Karina I mean I'll just say again
that when we have such a huge portion of
our trips that are relatively short
distance trips that we still continue to
drive and predominantly drive in single
occupant vehicles that again creating a
walkable community a bikable community
really enticing these zero emission
modes of travel and making them more
viable in our urban environments and in
the suburban environments as well
creating Complete Streets increasing
safety really paying attention to the
human experience this pays dividends on
any number of levels well thank you I
would love for all of you to join me in
thanking our panel for a wonderful
conversation
[Applause]
[Music]